ننتقل الى مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك
ومعنى من هناك ستيفان دوجريكا المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده مرحبا بك
موقف الامين العام للامم المتحده ازاء ما
يجري حاليا في غزه
للغايه حول
تفاقم الوضع وتدهوره في غزه وفي اسرائيل
مع تصاعد موجه العنف التي نراها الان
الذين يدفعون الثمن الاكبر هم المدنيون
وراينا اعداد كبيره من الضحايا في غزه بمن
فيهم الاطفال والمدنيين وراينا ايضا
الضحايا في اسرائيل
مبعوث على الارض يتواصل مع الاطراف في
محاوله
لتخفيف التوتر وانهاء هذا العنف ما الذي
يقوم به تحديدا وعمليا مبعوث الامم
المتحده على الارض
ناحيه العمليه هو في القدس وهو يتواصل
هاتفيا مع كل الاطراف المعنيه داخل
اسرائيل وداخل غزه وما هو ابعد من ذلك وهو
يدفع بنفس الرساله وهي الحاجه الى انهاء
فوري لهذا العنف كلما ازداد العمر كلما
زادت المعاناه راينا في غزه ما يحدث ونعرف
انه وضع ماساويا للاطفال وهو صعب اصلا
للعيش في غزه في ظل هذه الظروف لكن عندما
تغلق المدارس ويستمر العنف الامر هذا يزيد
من التوتر والصعوب على الاطفال
وهل اسفرت
محادثاته عن اي شيء
هو الدليل ما يحدث على الارض وهو استمرار
العنف وهذا لن يرضعنا عن بدل جهودنا لرؤيه
نهايه هذا انتم تعلمون احسن منا ان الوضع
معقد للغايه وهناك عده قوى سياسيه تفعل
فعلها لكننا نستمر في برلي قصاره جهدنا
هل تلك الجهود التي تقوم بها الامم
المتحده جهود منسقه مع اطراف دوليه او
اقليميه اخرى ومن هي ان كان نعم
نحن نبقى على اتصال وثيق مع الاعضاء
الاخرين في الرباعيه وبالطبع مع السلطات
المصريه التي لها دور كبير ان تلعبه مع
اخرين ايضا وواضح ان الجميع في المجتمع
الدولي يريد رؤيه اشياء نفسه ونعمل ان
يعمل الجميع بنفس الاتجاه فصائل المقاومه
تطالب كشرط
لوقف اطلاق النار ان تتوقف سياسه
الاغتيالات من قبل اسرائيل
يعني الى اي مدى تعتقد بان هذا المطلب
يمكن تحقيقه وما هو موقف الامم المتحده من
سياسه او الامين العام للامم المتحده من
سياسه الاغتيالات التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
نحن لا نستطيع انا لن اتفاوض بالنيابه عن
الجهاز الاسلامي او الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هذا ليس من وظيفه وليس من وظيفتي ان نقوم
بذلك علنا كما قلت نحن على اتصال مع كل
الاطراف لنرى ان كانت هناك ارضيه مشتركه
وصولا الى وقف فوري للقتال ووقف فوري
للهجمات الصاروخيه
والعنف الذي الذي
المدنيون في فلسطين وفي اسرائيل يعانون
منه فقط موضوع
سياسه الاغتيالات يعني الحرب بدات
بالاغتيال الذي قامت به اسرائيل لثلاثه من
قاده السرايا القدس ما هو الموقف مما تقوم
به اسرائيل على بهذه النقطه تحديدا
تعلمون ان ان استمرار وضع العلاقه بين
اسرائيل وبين الفصائل الفلسطينيه المختلفه
ليس وضعا جيدا
لا يمكن ان نقول في اي نقطه بدات الامور
تزداد في الامس القريب او الماضي البعيد
الوضع نحن نقف ضد
الاجراءات اجراءات القتل خارج اطار
القانون ونحن قلنا ذلك في عده سياقات
والقانون الدولي واضح اذا هذه الحاله الكل
لديه
الحقوق ولديه الواجبات نريد رؤيه نهايه
لهذا العنف ونريد حل سياسيا لمصلحه
المدنيين في كلا طرفي هذا النزاع المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده شكرا
جزيلا لك